bonjour et bienvenue dans le journal de
l'outre-mer un nouveau départ pour
lutter contre le chikungunya l'île de la
réunion décide de mettre les bouchées
doubles contre le virus africain
transmis par le moustique
dix mille personnes auraient contracté
la maladie en dix mois mais les chiffres
de l'épidémie font l'objet de
contestations
en effet des médecins ont contesté ces
chiffres
trente deux généralistes installés dans
le sud de l'île se sont regroupés pour
réclamer la vérité sur l'ampleur de
l'épidémie
certains évoquent plus de 30 mille cas
en tout cas la polémique sur cette
affaire dépasse les frontières du
département et les parlementaires
s'empare du dossier au sénat la
communiste gélita hoarau a demandé aux
gouvernements quels moyens il comptait
mettre en oeuvre pour endiguer
l'épidémie
tout en rajoutant il ne s'agit pas
monsieur le ministre d'un problème de
soude de financiers il s'agit d'un plan
d'organiser avec tous les acteurs sur le
terrain pour essayer d'éradiquer nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 600000 euros qui
ont été mobilisés je vous le dis très
clairement
s'il faut aller au delà il vient nous
irons au delà parce qu'il importe
justement de dégager les moyens
financiers pour avoir les moyens
matériels et humains sur place pour
pouvoir lutter contre la maladie
quoi qu'il en soit à saint denis le
préfet de région a convoqué une réunion
de crise il en sera ainsi chaque semaine
il est vrai que dans dix jours c'est la
rentrée des classes c'est pourquoi les
pouvoirs publics viennent de former 120
personnes aptes à des moustiques et les
collèges et les lycées